so you probably heard the name julian
assange and you probably gathered from
all the shouting about julian assange
from our political class that he's some
sort of international spy who hacked our
computers and stole our secrets
but that's not at all what julian
assange is or has ever been he didn't
hack anybody's computers he's a
journalist he reprinted facts that were
deeply embarrassing to our political
class the democratic national committee
and to above all the foreign policy
establishment which has an awful lot to
be embarrassed of
and for doing that the new york times
done things like that for a hundred
years no problem julian assange does it
well he's been incarcerated for almost a
decade since the summer of 2012.
he's now for the last two odd years been
in maximum security prison in the uk
he could be coming to this country
so what exactly is going to happen next
with julian assange and why is no one
defending him
gabriel shipton is julian assange's
brother he joins us tonight
ms chipton thanks so much for coming on
and by the way when i say no one's
defending of course many people are
defending julian assange but i mean no
one
at the higher reaches of american
journalism for example they are silent
on this why do you think that is
well i think tucker they've been able to
ignore this uh case
for a while you know
it'd been at arm's length in the uk
but
just last friday the uk high court ruled
that um julian uh could be extradited uh
they approved the extradition
to the usa so
uh the case is now coming here you know
julian has a chance to appeal but uh it
was the height it was the chief justice
the chief justice of uh the uk who's the
highest judge in england and wales who
who ordered the extradition so it's very
unlikely uh that appeal will go ahead so
i think that people here can uh can the
the media uh
the government can no longer ignore that
this case is coming this uh you know
this criminalization
of it's basically a biden administration
the biden administration has
criminalized telling the truth with this
indictment and it's even worse than that
actually they've criminalized knowing uh
about classified information and so
now it's coming to this country the
extradition has been ordered by the high
court uh i don't think people here can
can any longer ignore ignore it
you've got to ask yourself though and i
don't think you live in the united
states but we're in the middle of a
crime wave in which many thousands of
people have been killed uh over and
above last year's numbers in which many
thousands more have died of drug
overdoses from drugs are coming so we
have a lot of crime problems in the
united states right now but the body
administration is very focused on
getting its hands on your brother
why is getting your brother more
important than bringing say murderers to
justice
well i think the people you know the
people who run our democracies now would
like like to rule them uh
you know with impunity they don't want
people to know what's being done in
their name
uh they want to keep secrets uh they
want to uh
they don't want the public to be
informed basically i think i think
that's that's why and they're creating
julian they're making an example out of
julian they're saying to people if you
uh tell the truth about our secrets if
you
uh tell the truth about the security
state or or or anything really this is
what's going to happen to you
you're going to be locked in a prison
for the rest of your life
uh your you will be your reputation will
be destroyed uh you'll be taken away
from your family
i have to ask you a final question which
is a depressing question but i have to
ask if your brother is extradited to the
united states do you think he'll survive
look no no i don't i mean you know we we
can look you know look
prisoners here can't be kept safe even
the most high-profile prisoners uh like
jeffrey epstein he couldn't be kept safe
in prison you know so uh what hope what
hope will julian have here i think uh i
think you know if if he gets extradited
he will most likely die
ah you make this sound like bolivia
which makes me ashamed but you're
probably not wrong
gabriel thank you so much for coming on
tonight i appreciate it